and some of the other studios what's  montreal up to right now well we have  our veteran team behind assassin's creed  valhalla in montreal the birthplace of  assassins creed who's been hard at work  on a new flagship title as well it is  being led by uh creative director clint  hawking it is a very different type of  assassin's creed game  and i believe you may have brought us  something that we can watch now yes here  it is  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  well the surprises just keep on coming  what can you tell us about this project  well this is code name hexay and i can't  wait for our fans to tear apart that  trailer and find out all its secrets